Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast über Raumfahrt und andere kosmische Angelegenheiten. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle hier zur 70. Ausgabe unserer Gesprächsrunde. Das Ganze wie immer mit Unterstützung der Stiftung Planetarien in Berlin. Heute geht es mal nicht so sehr in die Technik oder in sonstige Raumfahrterfahrungswelten oder vielleicht auch doch. Heute wollen wir uns nämlich mal das Recht anschauen, das Weltraumrecht, was all das umgibt, was wir hier bisher schon besprochen haben. Und dazu begrüße ich meinen Gesprächspartner Stefan Hube. Schönen guten Tag Herr Hube. Ja, wir sind in Köln hier an ihrem Institut, Institut für Luft- und Raumfahrtrecht. Sie sind ja hier schon eine Weile am Walten und auch das Thema Raumfahrt hat sie ja, glaube ich, relativ früh erfasst. Wie sind Sie denn so zum Recht gekommen?
Das ist eine ganz spannende Sache. Ich habe nicht meine juristische Ausbildung mit dem Weltraumrecht angefangen. Das ist erst eine spätere Spezialisierung geworden, als ich auf der Suche nach der juristischen Grundausbildung, auf der Suche nach einem interessanten Dissertationsthema gewesen bin, also an der Doktorarbeit, wollte ich ursprünglich mit dem Seerecht arbeiten, dort was schreiben, aber die betreuenden Professoren sagten, das sei mehr oder minder ausgelutscht, nicht mehr interessant. Ich solle mal in eine neue Dimension vorstoßen und etwas Weltraumrechtliches schreiben. Da guckte ich die Professoren sehr erstaunt an und es entfuhren mir die Sätze. Gibt es denn sowas überhaupt? Später habe ich das dann intensiv studiert, auch im Ausland studiert. Bin meiner Herkunft nach Völkerrechtler, habe im Völkerrecht auch habilitiert und habe entsprechend einen Lehrstuhl in Köln für Völkerrecht, Europarecht, internationales Wirtschaftsrecht und Investitionsrecht. Und darüber hinaus leite ich das sehr alte, traditionsreiche Institut für Luft- und Weltraumrecht, welches es schon seit 1925 gibt.
Aber das sich am Anfang wahrscheinlich mehr mit der Luft beschäftigt hat, als mit dem Weltraumrecht.
Deshalb genau. Luft- und Weltraumrecht 1925. Auch ein Pioniergeist, das war die Frühzeit der Luftfahrt, auch des Luftfahrtrechts, als Otto Schreiber dieses Institut damals auch nicht in Köln, sondern in Königsberg gegründet hat. Es ist erst nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg dann nach Köln umgezogen und 1951, vor allem in meinem Vorvorgänger Alex Meyer, hier wieder begründet worden. Ich bin erst der sechste Direktor dieses Instituts, woran sie erkennen mögen, dass es eine gewisse Haltwertzeit hat, hier zu sein, mit den vielen spannenden Aufgaben zu tun hat.
Was macht denn so als Jurist den Reiz eines Feldes aus? Wenn Sie sagen, Anfangs so Seerecht und Sie wussten noch nicht so ganz genau, wonach sucht man denn?
Man sucht nach rechtlichen Herausforderungen, die immer umso stärker sind, je mehr Herausforderungen es durch ungeahnte neue Entwicklungen geben kann. Und das ist nun sicherlich für die Luftfahrt zum einen, aber insbesondere auch für die Raumfahrt ganz besonders der Fall, weil wir technologische Entwicklungen haben, die einfach sehr, dass auch die rechtliche Kodifikation sehr auf die Probe stellen. Ich bin gleichzeitig Rechtsberater der Deutschen Delegation im UN-Weltraum-Ausschuss, wo es also um die Kodifikation von Verhaltensformen geht. Und da werden wir ständig konfrontiert mit Fragen, die wir vielleicht im Lauf des Gesprächs auch noch mal weiter verfolgen können. Wie es etwa um den Umweltschutz im Weltraum steht, ob es heutzutage angängig ist, Ressourcen von den Himmelskörpern zu holen und sie zu verarbeiten, ob und inwieweit überhaupt private Raumfahrt zulässig ist und zulässig sein soll. Dies alles garniert von den obwaltenden Problemen, die darin bestehen, dass die Raumfahrt ja zu allererst militärisch basiert gewesen und das bis heute ist. Alle großen Weltraumnationen haben eine ganz starke militärische Fokussierung. Die Vereinigten Staaten Amerika, Russland, China, Indien, um nur mal die ganz starken Raumfahrtnationen zu nennen. Europa hat das ausdrücklich nicht. Europa hat sich ja zusammengeschlossen in der europäischen Raumfahrtagentur, weil die Staaten zu klein sind und die Weltraumfahrt eben unendlich viel Geld kostet, so dass man sich da auf eine reine Research, also Forschungsorientierung, teilweise mit Anwendungsorientierung konzentriert hat und nicht das, was man sonst unter der Dual-Use-Technologie versteht, dass sie also einen Satelliten zur Ressourcenauffindung, aber genauso gut zur Spionage benutzen können, also friedlich und militärisch, dass das in Europa keine Rolle spielt.
Also zumindest nicht die vorherrschende Rolle.
Naja, bisher sagt die europäische Weltraumagentur gibt es, es gibt kein einziges Anwendungsprogramm der ESA, das irgendeine militärische Konnotation hätte. Einzelstaaten sicher, Frankreich sicher, das Vereinigte Königreich sicher, Deutschland aus bekannten Gründen nicht, aber diese beiden sind natürlich Raumfahrtnationen, die ihr eigenes nationales militärisches Weltraumprogramm, beides Atommächte, haben und sie müssen eben sehen, dass im Grunde genommen die Weltraumfahrt und die Nutzung der Nuklearenergie, das Abschreckungspotenzial, was davon ausgeht, eng miteinander verbunden sind, weil eben erst durch die Möglichkeit, diese interkontinentale Raketen auf in Stellung zu bringen und sie mit nuklearen Sprengköpfen zu versehen, die besondere Abschreckungsmöglichkeit ausmacht.
Vielleicht noch mal auf die Geschichte, wie sich das Recht überhaupt entwickelt hat, blicken. Wo müsste man da ansetzen? Ist das im Prinzip so, dass die ersten Grundzüge schon mit der Luftfahrt dann auch wirklich so codiert wurden oder ist Weltraumrecht noch mal eine ganz eigene Entwicklung?
Das wirkliche Weltraumrecht beginnt erst, sich zu entwickeln nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg, aber man hat sozusagen in der Frühzeit der Weltraumfahrt und die haben sehr viel mit Werner von Braun und seiner für Hitler gefertigten Raketen zur Verteidigung, aber auch zur Aggression Deutschlands zu tun, also ist in den 1920er, 1930er Jahren anzusiedeln. Schon in dieser Zeit gibt es 25 Jahre vor dem ersten künstlichen Satelliten aus dem Jahr 1932 ein Buch eines Deutsch-Tschechen, Wladimir Mandl, der ein Buch über Weltraumrecht schreibt. Er nimmt da und da haben sie sehr recht mit ihrer Vermutung, die die Frage nahe liegt. Nimmt da das Luftrecht zur Grundlage und versucht sozusagen Analogien zu ziehen, sagt auch schon im Weltraum darf es keine staatliche Souveränität geben, wo ja klar ist, dass jeder Staat über seinen Luftraum volle Souveränität ausübt. Also ein ganz anderes rechtliches Kontinuum dort ist. Nein, aber das Weltraumrecht beginnt eigentlich erst in der in der in der Genealogie nach dem Start des ersten künstlichen Satelliten nach dem zweiten Weltkrieg am 4. Oktober 1957. Das alarmiert vor allem die Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika extrem, weil Russland, die damalige Souveränität, damit den Nachweis geführt hatte, dass sie mit Intercontinental-Raketen sozusagen von Vladivostok nach Los Angeles kommen konnte. Die weitere Geschichte ist aber keine bilaterale, sondern eine innerhalb der Vereinten Nationen. Dort wird Weltraumrecht geschrieben. Man braucht etwa zehn Jahre, um den ersten großen Vertrag abzuschließen, den noch heute gültigen Weltraumvertrag, wie er abgekürzt heißt, in dem eigentlich alle Grundsätze festgelegt sind. Dann ein Jahr später ein Weltraumrettungsabkommen, in dem es im Wesentlichen darum geht, was muss man machen, was soll man machen, wenn Astronauten in Schwierigkeiten kommen, entweder im Weltraum oder eben beim Start oder bei der Landung. Dann 1972 ein Weltraumhaftungsabkommen, in dem festgelegt wird, wer eigentlich haftet, wenn ein Satellit auf die Erde kommt oder wenn zwei Satelliten im Weltraum kollidieren. Schließlich 1975 das Registrierungsabkommen, wo es darum geht, dass jeder, der einen Weltraumgegenstand, einen Satelliten etwa im Weltraum schießt, der dafür auch ein Register haben muss und den registrieren muss und da bestimmte Informationen über den Satelliten festlegen muss, festhalten muss. Und schließlich 1979 das am strittenste dieser ganzen Abkommen, das internationale Mondabkommen, was für den Mond und andere Himmelskörper, also auch für den Mars, die Venus und so weiter gilt, wo etwas über die Nutzung der Himmelskörper gesagt werden soll, dies allerdings nur in Ansätzen getan wird und eigentlich wir bis heute keine wirkliche Nutzungsordnung haben.
Aber damit wurden dann zumindest schon mal erst mal die ersten großen Probleme erledigt. Ich meine, das ist im Prinzip das erste Recht, was dann tatsächlich auf Basis der Vereinten Nationen überhaupt erst seine Geburt genommen hat, wo es auch so keine Vorlage gab.
Richtig, ganz richtig. Ja, in gewisser Weise gibt es zwei, grosso modo zwei Vorlagen. Das sind die anderen Staatengemeinschaftsräume, die wir kennen. Etwa der Tiefseeboden und dessen Nutzung, die Hohe See und deren Nutzung und auch die Antarktis und deren Nichtnutzung, die ja bis heute sozusagen verboten ist. Das sind Staatengemeinschaftsräume, die kein Staat über diese Gebiete eigene Souveränität ausüben. Und die unterlagen schon teilweise davor eigentlich der Verwaltung durch die Vereinten Nationen, die deshalb auch entsprechend das Recht in Staatenkonferenzen gemacht hat. Daher also Völkerrecht. Das ist ja nichts anderes als zwischenstaatlich gemachtes Recht.
Das heißt, das Völkerrecht ist im Prinzip die Basis für all diese Abkommen? Was ist denn in diesen Abkommen jetzt genau festgehalten? Fangen wir vielleicht mal mit diesem Weltraumvertrag an. Offizieller Langtitel heißt es hier Vertrag über die Grundsätze zur Regelung der Tätigkeiten von Staaten bei der Erforschung und Nutzung des Weltraums, einschließlich des Mondes und anderer Himmelskörper. Schöner Titel.
Ja, da finden sie etwa die wichtigste Bestimmung, dass nämlich weder der Weltraum noch Himmelskörper staatliche Aneignung unterliegen. In anderen Worten, die amerikanische Flagge auf dem Mond zeigt nicht etwa, dass der Mond der 51. Staat der Vereinigten Staaten wäre, sondern signalisiert, hier sind Menschen gewesen, eine neue Dimension vorgestoßen, als, wie es so schön heißt, Boten der Menschheit, Envoys of Mankind, wie es im Weltraumvertrag auch drin entsteht. Dann etwa eine Klausel über die begrenzte Demilitarisierung des Weltraums und vor allem der Himmelskörper. Man darf keine Massenvernichtungswaffen etwa auf dem Mond und anderen Himmelskörpern stationieren. Wohl aber, da ist bewusst eine Lücke gelassen worden, darf man sie im Weltraum benutzen. Keine Massenvernichtungswaffen, aber jedenfalls Waffen, die sozusagen etwa erlauben würden, intercontinental Raketen schießen zu können. Dann gibt es aber für die Himmelskörper ein striktes Demilitarisierungsgebot. Schließlich die besondere Erlaubnis, dass auch private Weltraumaktivitäten unternehmen dürfen, dafür aber die Erlaubnis eines Staates brauchen. Schließlich eine Klausel, die festlegt, dass wenn man einen Schaden im Weltraum oder auf der Erde verursacht, der sogenannte Startstaat, der Staat, der nämlich dieses Weltraumobjekt in den Weltraum gebracht hat, für den entstandenen Schaden haftet.
Also ein bisschen so wie Eltern haften für ihre Kinder, müssen auch die Staaten für ihre Unternehmen haften.
Ganz genau. Eltern, Staaten haften für ihre Unternehmen. Das ist etwas auch völkerrechtlich sehr besonderes, das sozusagen dazu führen soll, dass Staaten entsprechend gucken, dass sie die Unternehmen, denen sie das einer solchen Erlaubnis, einer Lizenz zum Betreiben privater Aktivitäten geben, dass die sich auch anständig versichern. Denn sonst können sie gegenüber denen keinen Rückgriff nehmen, wenn mal was passieren sollte. Schließlich eine Registrierungspflicht, die Tatsache, dass Staaten über Satelliten doch eine Art von rechtlicher Kontrolle behalten. Denn sonst würden die da ja, weil es kein genuines Orbitrecht gibt, muss man sich des staatlichen Rechts bedienen. Deshalb gilt etwa an Bord der Internationalen Raumstation pro Modul unterschiedliches Recht, je nachdem, welcher Staat dieses Modul zusammenfabriziert hat und in den Weltraum geschossen hat. Und dann gibt es eine Vorschrift, die ein bisschen an einen löchrigen Schweizer Käse erinnert. Das sind erste Ansätze, wir befinden uns damals im Jahr 1967 von einer Art Umwelt- Weltraumrecht. Das ist allerdings so verklausuliert und so unkonkret formuliert, dass man sagen kann, 1967 war die Menschheit in der Tat noch nicht so weit tatsächlich, wie wir das heute sehr stark haben. Aber erst seit der Stockholm Umweltkonferenz von 1972 hier schon rigide Absprachen zum Schutze des Weltraums und der Himmelskörper zu treffen. Damit ist der Weltraumvertrag der umfassendste und viele der Einzelnen dort enthaltenen Prinzipien. Rettung von Astronauten, Haftung für Schäden, Registrierung sind später wieder aufgenommen worden in spezifischen Abkommen. Dort wird also dann noch detaillierter das beschrieben. In einem Fall, den ich noch nicht angesprochen habe, spricht der Weltraumvertrag auch sehr unvollkommen von der Möglichkeit der Nutzung des Weltraums. Und schreibt und sagt dazu, dass diese Nutzung des Weltraums Anliegen der gesamten Menschheit sein soll. Hier ist der Jurist gefordert. Das ist ja eine mittelmäßig unbestimmte Klausel. Was ist Anliegen der gesamten Menschheit? Wir sind uns heute im Wesentlichen darüber einig, dass wir nicht präzise angeben können, was das heißt. Wohl ist richtig, dass die damaligen Väter und Mütter dieser Bestimmungen im Auge hatten, dass Staaten nicht nur exklusive Vorteilsnutzung aus dem Weltraum ziehen sollten, sondern dass der Weltraum eben ein Staatengemeinschaftsraum ist, dessen Vorteile in welcher Form auch immer der gesamten Menschheit zugutekommen soll. Beginnen aber erst die Probleme, denn heißt das jetzt, dass ein bestimmter Prozentsatz jeder Nutzung sozusagen ausgeschüttet werden soll, schuldet man bestimmten Staaten das. Darüber geht bis heute der Streit und der konkretisiert sich heute an der Tatsache, ob eigentlich man Ressourcen sozusagen von Himmelskörpern schürfen kann, was technologisch, wie mir Technologie-Kollegen sagen, noch nicht möglich sein soll, aber da die Technologie sich sehr wahnsinnig schnell fortentwickelt, vielleicht schon in absehbarer Zeit möglich sein kann. Und das werden wir sicher in einem extra Bereich nochmal besprechen. Da ist ganz unklar, wie das Recht sich dazu verhält.
Aber steht so drin, Anliegen der Menschheit. Was könnte denn das sein?
Anliegen der Menschheit könnte sein, dass kein Staat exklusiv, also ausschließlich, den Vorteil der Weltraumfahrt nutzen kann. Sondern, dass das in gewisser Weise allen Staaten der gesamten Menschheit zugutekommen soll. Jedenfalls wird man ja immer argumentieren können, der Wissensgewinn, den man sozusagen dadurch hat. Das sind ja tatsächlich Quantensprünge, wenn man in den Materialwissenschaften, wenn man etwa für pharmazeutische Produkte, wenn man überhaupt das Verhalten des menschlichen Körpers unter dem Einfluss verminderte oder kaum vorhandene Schwerkraft erforschen kann, hat und wenn man so Beispiel sehen kann, welche Auswirkungen Mikrogravitation oder nicht vorhandene Schwerkraft auf den menschlichen Körper, auf den Knochenbau zum Beispiel, hat welche wahnsinnige Langzeitwirkungen das hat, dann sind das sicherlich Dinge, die der Operationstechnik in der Zukunft natürlich zugutekommen. Nicht nur die berühmte Teflon-Fanne, die sozusagen, wie man immer sprichwörtlich sagt, mal ein Produkt der Weltraumfahrt gewesen sein soll.
Ja, an der Stelle erlauben Sie mir den kurzen Verweis für Hörer, die vielleicht noch nicht rein gehört haben. Die 21. Ausgabe, ein Gespräch mit Robert Gerzer beim DLR Köln über Weltraummedizin, wo viele von diesen Aspekten auch schon zur Sprache kamen. Aber was heißt das jetzt, das Anliegen, also, habe ich Sie jetzt so verstanden, heißt nicht, dass wenn ich jetzt als Staat Raumfahrt betreibe, damit automatisch sozusagen für die ganze Menschheit arbeiten muss oder heißt es nur, man muss es allen auch ermöglichen, das für sich auch zu machen?
Auslegungsfrage. Umstritten. Ich würde es wie in letzterer Weise auslegen, da das Weltraumrecht bisher nicht konkret ist und das ist eigentlich meine Geschichte, die ich Ihnen erzählen möchte. Diese ungenaue Formulierung ist versucht worden oder muss noch konkretisiert werden. Das wird klar, weil wir uns jetzt stundenlang die Frage stellen, was heißt denn nun Anliegen der Menschheit?
Wer ist die Menschheit und was ist ein Anliegen?
Wie viel muss denn geteilt werden? Das muss noch in einer konkreten Nutzungsordnung festgedichtet werden. Staaten haben damit begonnen, als in 1979 das Mondabkommen zustande gebracht haben. Aber sie haben damals gesagt, in weiser Voraussicht, wir wissen noch zu wenig über die Nutzung der Himmelskörper, wir wollen erst eine konkrete Nutzungsordnung in dem Moment machen, wo wir konkret an die Nutzung herangehen beziehungsweise wo die absehbar ist. Diese Zeit könnte in absehbarer Zeit anbrechen. Deshalb mein Pädoyer gar ein ganz entschiedenes ist, fangt damit an, eine solche Nutzungsordnung aufzustellen. Das ist bekanntlich immer dann sehr schwierig, wenn es schon Staaten gibt, die nutzen, weil die dann gar kein Interesse mehr haben, irgendwelche Kompromisse zu machen. Mein Eindruck ist so ein bisschen, dass es einige Staaten gibt, die alles daran setzen, möglichst zu keinen internationalen Abkommen über diese Frage zu kommen, um nämlich sich entsprechende Vorteile zu verschaffen.
Wie muss man sich denn das vorstellen, diesen Diskurs der Einigung auf UN, auf Völkerrechtsebene? War das von Anfang an immer schon schwierig, wird immer schwierig bleiben oder gab es da auch eine Phase des großen Konsens, wo man irgendwie mit Respekt voreinander getreten ist und sich da schnell einig war? Weil im Prinzip ist das ja alles relativ früh schon entstanden. Wenn man jetzt mal sieht, dass die UN selber erst 45 überhaupt erst gestartet wurde und noch ganz andere Sorgen hatte, dass dann gleich in dem Rahmen so ein Rechtswerk entstanden ist.
Naja, ich meine, das spricht eben dafür, dass zwischen 1967 und 1979 fünf internationale Abkommen entstanden sind. Das ist ganz enorm. In fünf Abkommen hat man sich auf einen Text einigen können. Bei meinem ganz sicheren Gefühl wäre das heute nicht mehr möglich. Wir haben eine Krise der Völkerrechtsbildung, wir haben eine Krise Staatenkonsense hinzubekommen. Man hat das damals leichter hinbekommen. Die internationale Gemeinschaft ist diverser geworden, auch in ihren Interessen. Wir haben stärker pronuncierte, sich entwickelnde Staaten. Zum Beispiel ist ein Staat wie Indien sehr viel pronuncierter. China hat ganz eigene Interessen und möchte gerade nicht mit den Interessen der Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika oder auch von Russland in einen Topf geworfen werden. Es wird also unendlich schwierig. Alle wollen sie berücksichtigt werden. Deshalb sehen sie es typischerweise auch im Umweltrecht. Wie schwierig es ist, einen Konsens über entsprechende Klimaschutz- abkommen hinzubekommen. Jeder muss da sein eigenes, seine eigenen Interessen zur Geltung bringen. Es ist sehr schwierig bei 193 Staaten, das alles deckungsgleich zu bekommen. Das merken wir seit 1979 gibt es eben anstelle dieser verbindlichen Abkommen nur noch unverbindliche Resolutionen der Generalversammlung. Man sagt ausdrücklich, wir wollen uns nicht schlussendlich einigen, wir wollen nur was unverbindliches produzieren. Das sind dann, wenn sie so wollen, Guidelines, aber eben nicht rechtlich verbindlich. Keinem Staat kann mehr vorgeworfen werden, er halte das Recht nicht ein, weil es kein verbindliches Recht gibt. Ich als Völkerrechter kann das nur schärfstens brandmarken, weil es im Ergebnis kontraproduktiv ist zu dem wesentlichsten Errungenschaft völkerrechtlicher Einigungen, das nämlich Völkerrecht im Zweifel dem Schwächeren dient, der sich auf eine Abmachung verlassen kann. Der Stärkere ist sowieso stark genug, das zu tun, was er möchte. Der hat sogar ein flagrantes Interesse daran, dass möglichst wenig vereinbart wird, um entsprechend Ellenbogen-Freiheit für weitere Aktionen zu haben. Nur der Schwache, der kann nicht anders, weil er de facto wirtschaftlich, militärisch überhaupt zu schwach ist, das an den Interessen der Großmächte vorbei zu tun. Insofern erleben wir in meinen Augen in erschreckender Weise, sozusagen das Wiedererstarken an archischer Zustände. Und das kann ich als Völkerrecht dann keiner Weise gut heißen.
Denken sie, ist es nur eine Phase?
Ich glaube, es ist dann eine Phase, wenn sich die Staaten darauf besinnen, dass das, was im Weltraumvertrag so richtig steht, Weltraum und Weltraumnutzung ein Anliegen der gesamten Menschheit ist. Lass mich das an einem Beispiel verdeutlichen. Wichtige Umlaufbahnen um die Erde, sind schon seit 1957 ständig genutzt worden. Die Konsequenz ist, dass sie zunehmend vermüllen. Kleine und kleinste Partikel an Müll entstehen und machen diese Umlaufbahnen, versetzen diese Umlaufbahnen in einen Zustand von denen Experten und wir haben in Deutschland ganz besondere Experten in diesem Bereich, sagen, dass sie jedenfalls zwar jetzt noch nicht, aber in 30, 40 Jahren zur nicht mehr Nutzbarkeit dieser Orbits führen und das einfach so gefährlich ist, dass kleinste Debris-Partikel, also dieser Weltraummüll, wegen der enormen Geschwindigkeit von 9,7 Meter pro Sekunde in ihrem Aufprall intakte Satelliten zerstören können. Es wird also zu einem unberechenbaren Risiko das zu tun. Nun wird eines deutlich, die Raumfahrt-Nationen und alle anderen, also eigentlich die gesamte Menschheit, hat kein Interesse daran, dass unser ganzes Telekommunikationssystem, was ja in ganz starkem Umfang bis hin zu Handys und so weiter abhängt von der Nutzung des Weltraums, ist kaum jemandem bewusst, wie stark wir abhängig sind davon, dass also diese ganze Telekommunikations- Infrastruktur lahmgelegt wird. Das könnte sein, wie es auch bei irrtischem Umweltrecht ist, Stichwort Klimawandel, dass irgendwann doch eine Erkenntnis aufkommt, dass es nichts bringt, dass es vor allem dem eigenen Anliegen überhaupt nicht weiter hilft, auf eigener Stärke zu beharren, sondern dass es nur etwas bringt, Staaten gemeinschaftliche Lösungen zu finden, wo gegebenenfalls im Bereich des Burden-Sharing derjenige mehr ran muss, der auch mehr leisten kann und derjenige weniger leisten muss, aber auch was leisten muss, der weniger kann. Das ist meine Hoffnung, dass sozusagen, wie das immer oder sehr häufig der Fall gewesen ist, erst erst drei Minuten vor zwölf sein muss, bevor sich bestimmte Staaten bewegen. Das ist sehr bedauerlich, dass es so sein muss. Manchmal muss es auch erst fünf nach zwölf sein und mal kräftig gekracht haben, bevor Bewegung in diese Dinge reinkommt. Ich kann Ihnen berichten von ganz konkreten Verhandlungen, die wir führen, über einen Kodex verbindlicher Richtlinien, die dazu führen sollen, dass Staaten Debris- Partikel, also Müll, aus dem Weltraum zurückholen. Das wird in absehbarer Zeit möglich sein. Man kann da Netze auswerfen, man kann die angeln, man kann die mit einer Art Vacuum Cleaner einsaugen. Oder auch mit Licht wegschubsen. Tatsache ist, in diesem Ausschuss bewegen sich vor allem die großen Staaten keinen Zentimeter und finden jede Ausrede, warum das entweder technologisch nicht möglich sein soll, rechtlich angeblich ungerecht sein soll, zu entsprechenden Lösungen zu kommen. Und wenn man da nicht verzweifeln möchte, wo man ist manchmal kurz davor, dann kann man sich nur sagen, wahrscheinlich ist der Druck noch nicht groß genug. Wenn der erst wirklich groß ist und 5 vor 12, vielleicht kommen wir dann doch tatsächlich zur Lösung.
Wobei die Problematik ja schon, schon da ist. Satelliten sind zusammen gestoßen, aktive Satelliten werden am laufenden Meter von irgendetwas durchlöchert, was mit ziemlich großer Sicherheit menschlichen Ursprungs ist. Also das Problem nimmt ja zu.
Eindeutig. Und das verwundert deshalb ein bisschen. Bis überhaupt das Thema Weltraummüll in die Vereinten Nationen Einzug gehalten hatte, jedenfalls in den Rechtsausschuss Einzug gehalten hatte, ist ewige Zeit vergangen, wo immer wieder gesagt wurde, nein, nein, die technologische Entwicklung sah noch gar nicht so weit. Man kann überhaupt noch nicht überhaupt an Ansätze von Qualifizierung denken. Mittlerweile diskutieren wir es immerhin. Aber ob es sobald zu tatsächlicher Lösung, Problemlösung kommt, steht in meinen Augen etwas dahin.
Klingt ja ein bisschen merkwürdig, dass gerade die großen sich dagegen wehren, die ja eigentlich auch am meisten zu verlieren haben an der Stelle.
Das ist völlig richtig. Völlig richtig, aber sie fürchten natürlich, dass sie, wenn man bestimmte Grundsätze anlegen sollte, juristische Grundsätze, die man mal etwas großzügig heute auch schon vielleicht ansetzen könnte, dass es so etwas wie ein Verursacher-Prinzip gibt, der Verursacher dann vielleicht auch die Rechnung bezahlen darf, hauptsächlich, dass natürlich die bisherigen Weltraum-Nutzer diejenigen sind, die die Rechnung zu bezahlen haben.
Zumal es ja eine Menge Weltraumfahrzeuge gibt, die da oben noch rumgammeln, gar nicht mehr unter Kontrolle sind, weil einfach vor Kehrungsmaßnahmen wie, es geht hier nicht nur ums Starten, sondern muss auch einen Weg haben, das Ding wieder zurückzuführen, bevor es zu Schrott wird. Ja, eigentlich auch erst seit 10, 15 Jahren wirklich ein richtiges Thema sind.
Ganz genau, ganz genau, ganz genau. Wir haben das Problem, dass wir eben vergleichsweise spät dieses Thema aufgenommen haben, wie ja auch insgesamt die Frage des Umweltschutzes eher eine ist, die erst seit 1972 überhaupt ernsthaft seriös diskutiert wird.
Was sind denn, wenn man vielleicht noch mal bei den Rechtsgrundlagen bleiben, die auch akzeptiert sind, die vielleicht auch eingehalten werden, abgesehen von dem grundlegenden Weltraumvertrag, Sie erwähnten vorhin das Rettungsübereinkommen. Das klingt ja recht konkret. Ist das auch so konkret, wie es klingt?
Es ist auch so konkret, wie es klingt. Es gibt nur keine besonderen Fälle, wo das schon sehr intensiv mal angewendet wurde. Ich würde annehmen, das Weltraumrettungsabkommen kodifiziert eigentlich elementare Grundsätze der Humanität. Dass man einen Astronauten, der in Not geraten ist, nicht sozusagen in dieser Not umkommen lässt, ist eigentlich klar und ist eigentlich auch etwas, was das Völkerrecht insgesamt so sieht. Das ist entsprechend kodifiziert worden, das findet auch keinerlei Widerspruch, das wird man sagen, Krömmniss, eine auch über das geschriebene Vertragsrecht hinausgehende Pflicht. Also sie haben Recht, natürlich. Da haben wir es in der Tat mit der Kodifikation einer allgemeinen Regel zu tun, die von vielen Staaten akzeptiert ist, von sehr vielen Staaten akzeptiert ist.
Die aber noch nicht so richtig zum Einsatz gekommen ist.
Genau, dass ich da einen Staat darauf berufen hätte, ist nicht so. Staaten sind in diesen Fällen in der Regel sehr stark daran interessiert, andere nicht so sehr reingucken zu lassen in die Mission. Es gibt deshalb auch eine Rückführungspflicht in diesem Rettungsübereinkommen. Auf Kosten des Staatstaates ist der bergende Staat verpflichtet, das ins Tudeln gekommene Raumschiff zum Beispiel samt Astronauten rückzubestellen bzw. diese Astronauten in Krankenhäuser zu bringen oder in die entsprechende Quarantäne. Das ist ja mal erstmal nötig.
Sie erwähnten die ISS, dass sie ja nochmal so besondere Rechtsgrenzen hat. Wie ist denn, als das Projekt geboren wurde, die internationale Weltraumstation, war es ja allein schon, weil es eben international angelegt war und eben mal nicht eine Mission eines einzelnen Staates war, schon an sich eine Besonderheit. Waren Sie dazu zu irgendeinem Zeitpunkt vielleicht sogar auch konkret daran beteiligt? Ich könnte mir ja vorstellen, dass im Vorfeld der Planung der ISS auch an der rechtlichen Stelle von vornherein mit gearbeitet werden musste.
Das erste Abkommen über die Internationale Raumstation ist eines ohne die Russen gewesen, 1988. Das ist in Deutschland von Ministerium verhandelt worden. Ein toller internationaler Vertrag, den ich immer wieder meinen Studierenden vorführe. Der ist dann praktisch eins zu eins zehn Jahre später übernommen worden. Zu beiden Zeiten war ich noch nicht sozusagen in Amt und Würden als Direktor, bin das erst seit 2001. Hatte also das, im Prinzip habe ich das aus der Frosch- perspektive miterlebt, aber habe es nicht entsprechend aktiv mit beeinträchtigt einfließen können. Aber dieses ist ein sehr beeindruckendes Abkommen, muss man sagen. Es setzt eins zu eins die Regeln, die wir im internationalen Weltraumrecht, also etwa im Weltraumvertrag, haben um.
Und auf welche Art und Weise?
Indem etwa gesagt wird, dass innerhalb jedes, das erstes Mal jeder Staat, der ein Modul, die Weltraumstation ist aus verschiedenen Abteilungen sozusagen zusammengesetzt, man nennt diese Abteilungen Modul, dass jeder sozusagen Europa hat zum Beispiel das Columbus-Modul beigesteuert. Das sind verschiedene europäische Staaten in Deutschland, unter anderem in Bremen, gebaut worden und dann im Weltraum zusammengebaut worden. Vielen gar nicht klar, was eine unnorme Ingenieursleistung das ist. Das an Bord dieses Moduls, die europäische Staaten haben sich darauf geeinigt, französisches Recht gilt. Es gibt ja kein gemeineuropäisches Recht. Das an Bord des amerikanischen Moduls amerikanisches Recht gilt. Das an Bord des russischen Moduls russisches Recht gilt. Das ist direkt...
Die Japaner nicht zu vergessen.
Die Japaner nicht zu vergessen, den kanadischen Arm nicht zu vergessen. Also, man hat sich tatsächlich darauf eins zu eins übertragen, was im Artikel 8 des Weltraumverteidigungs auch steht, dass Staaten Hoheitsgewalt und Kontrolle über ihre Weltraumgegenstände auch dann haben, wenn die im Weltraum sind. Das führt zu weiteren interessanten Dingen, dass Urheberrechte, die für Erfindungen, die in den Modulen gemacht wurden, sich nach dem entsprechenden Recht des Staates richten oder dass das Strafrecht, wenn es zu strafbaren Handlungen kommen sollte, unter anderem in diesen Stationen auch das, unter anderem das Recht des Staates sind, der die entsprechenden Dinge da in den Weltraum geschickt hat.
Also man sollte nicht nur nicht klauen, sondern wenn man was klaut, dann sollte man überlegen, in welchem Gebiet, wo man am wenigst auf die Finger klickt. Ich stelle mir gerade vor, dass es so am Ende des amerikanischen Moduls auch so ein You are leaving the American Sector steht.
Sehr, sehr gut. Ich bin auch sehr glücklich insofern, dass es diese Regeln gibt, weil das immer ein Bestandteil meiner weltraumrechtlichen Klausur ist. Da können sich Studierende dann austoben. Eigentlich nicht so furchtbar schwer, aber man muss schon so ein bisschen konstruieren. Das ist immer sehr geeignet.
Aber gibt es dann auch spezielles Recht, was explizit diesen Körper auch an sich beschreibt und die Interaktion, die dort stattfinden? Weil das ist ja sozusagen mehr so ein Patchwork-Staat auf einem gemeinsamen Raum. Das bringt ja interessante rechtliche Implikationen mit.
Na ja, einmal ist es tatsächlich Patchwork. Und alles, was die Station selbst betrifft, ist im Grunde genommen mitgenommenesirdisches Recht. Was das Fliegen der Station in bestimmten Umlaufbahnen betrifft, das ist Weltraumrecht. Das darf eben nur in bestimmten Umlaufbahnen fliegen. Kann das auch rein naturwissenschaftlich nur dort tun. Muss aber natürlich in freien Bereichen fliegen. Man darf bestimmte Dinge sozusagen nicht machen. Man darf andere Sachen machen. Es darf zum Beispiel dort keine militärische Aktivität stattfinden. Man darf damit nicht die Weltraumumwelt verdrecken. Das sind sozusagen die Limitationen, die Begrenzungen, die entsprechend die Freiheit, die als Grundsatz im Weltraumvertrag festgehalten ist, die Nutzungsfreiheit und die Forschungsfreiheit kennen. Diese entsprechenden Begrenzungen. Umwelt, Militär, Aneignung. Das sind die großen Begrenzungen, die wir haben.
Was sind so die Einflüsse des Umweltrechts dann zum Beispiel auf die ISS?
Geringe. Ganz geringe. Denn da wird man sagen müssen, dass was innerhalb der Station gilt, wird durch einen Code of Conduct, durch einen Verhaltenskodex für die Astronauten festgelegt sein. Natürlich gibt es dort entsprechende Experimente, die geschützt werden. Es gibt bestimmte Möglichkeiten, an Bord der Station entstandenen Müll zu speichern und wieder zur Erde zurückzubringen. Es wäre etwa nicht angängig, dann vielleicht mal doch die, das ist ja ein niedriger Erdorbit, wo die Station ist zwischen 180 und 220 Kilometer über den Meeresspiegel, dass man die da vielleicht mal Luca aufmacht und rausschmeißt. Das ginge klar gar nicht. Das würde auch vom internationalen Weltraum-Umweltrecht verboten sein.
Gibt es denn auch Aspekte dieser Internationalisierung, die auf dem Boden in irgendeiner Form greifen, also zum Beispiel für Spaceport, für die Weltraumflughäfen oder für die international agierenden Organisationen selber? Also auch so die ESA unterstellt ja zum Beispiel auch nicht so explizit einen einzigen Rechtsraum, wenn ich das richtig mitbekommen habe.
Ja, natürlich. Das ist ein gutes Beispiel. Es gibt nach wie vor weitgehend national betriebene Spaceports. Es gibt die Vereinten Nationen als internationale Organisation, die nach wie vor einen Teil der Weltraumgesetzgebung versucht. Und es gibt teilweise Strukturen, sowohl im Bereich der Unternehmen, Airbus ist zum Beispiel ein Weltraumunternehmen, auch ein Luftfahrtunternehmen, ein europäisches Unternehmen, was sozusagen den verschiedenen Nationen angehören, die da subscribieren, was seinen Mehrwert dadurch generiert, dass an verschiedenen europäischen Standorten Weltraumgegenstände fabriziert werden. Und das organisatorisch-administrative Gegenstück ist die Europäische Weltraumagentur mit Sitz in Paris, aber mit vielen Filialen, unter anderem dem Astronautenzentrum in Köln.
Oder das Kontrollzentrum in Darmstadt.
Zum Beispiel.
Wissenschaft in Spanien.
Spanien und so weiter und so fort. Estec in den Niederlanden. Genau, also verschiedene Dinge, die sozusagen das abgebildet wird, weil Europa schon von den finanziellen Ressourcen nur dann stark ist, wenn es die poolen kann. Und so sind heute 20 Staaten Mitglieder der Europäischen Weltraumagentur. Deutschland und Frankreich, sowie mit Abstrichen Italien und noch mit weiteren Abstrichen dann.
Aber gilt dann für diese Struktur ein anderes Recht?
Ja, es gibt in gewisser Weise ESA-Recht tatsächlich. Es gibt inner-Organisationsrecht. Und ESA ist ja so aufgebaut, dass sich Staaten an einer bestimmten Form von Programmen, also Aktivitäten beteiligen müssen und an anderen Aktivitäten beteiligen können, sodass Staaten entscheiden können, in welchem Umfang sie, vor allem finanziellen Umfang, sie sich beteiligen wollen, was für sie, und das ist das Geheimnis des großen Erfolgs der ESA, eine unmittelbare industriepolitische Konsequenz hat. Denn es gibt einen Grundsatz des ESA-Rechts, der sagt, das, was du finanziell in ein optionales Programm, also ein Wahlprogramm, investiert hast, kriegst du als Work Package, als Auftrag von der ESA zurück. Man nennt das Fair Return, Just Retour Prinzip, was damit dazu dient, sozusagen einen gewissen industriepolitischen Plafond, industriepolitische Strukturen, Weltraumstrukturen in den verschiedenen Mitgliedstaaten zu erhalten. Basiert auf der sehr vernünftigen Idee, dass es unendlich teuer ist, neue Strukturen irgendwo aufzubauen. Wir haben das auch in vielen mittel- und osteuropäischen Staaten, die alle früher von der Serfiedenon hundertprozentig abhängig gewesen sind. Nehmen sie Bulgarien, nehmen sie Ungarn, nehmen sie Polen, wo noch ganz wenig an Weltrauminfrastruktur ist. Die Russen haben nur für sich und vielleicht ein bisschen Ukraine und ein bisschen Kasachstan, weil da Baikonur war, genutzt und wenig ihren Satelliten sozusagen da überlassen. Das sieht heute ganz bitter aus. Da erst mal Weltrauminfrastruktur hinzubringen, ist schwierig, weil enorm kostspielig. Das ist ein bisschen ein neues Equilibrium. Wir haben ja gewollt nach der Öffnung der Mauer, dass sozusagen auch in diesem Bereich die ESA arrondiert wird. Sie hat jetzt mittelostropische Staaten dabei, aber die spielen praktisch keine Rolle.
Beziehungsweise sind noch auf der Suche nach einer neuen Rolle. Ich glaube, Rumänien wird demnächst etwas mehr einsteigen, so wie ich es gehört habe. Da ist natürlich dann ein langer Weg zu gehen. Noch mal die Nachfrage. Die Spaceports, also zum Beispiel Kourou, gilt da rein französisches Recht oder ist das auch noch mal so eine Sonderzone?
Weitgehend französisches Recht, was das Betreiben dieses Weltraumspaceports angeht. Auch das Unternehmen, welches Weltraum Starts macht, Ariane Spas, ist ein französisches Unternehmen, was sozusagen im ESA-Auftrag, der ESA weitestgehend für die Satellitenstart zur Verfügung steht. Aber natürlich streng profitorientiert, eines der erfolgreichsten Unternehmen derzeit, ein bisschen Konkurrenz mit dem sehr aufstrebenden, jungen Unternehmen der Amerikaner, SpaceX, die beileibe nicht nur privat sind, sondern kräftig von, sozusagen, Nachfolger der Shuttle-Dinge, die ja Government waren, jetzt kräftig von Staat subventioniert werden bzw. mit Aufträgen gefüttert werden, aber eine enorm erfolgreiche Bilanz haben, glaube ich, im letzten Bilanzjahr die erfolgreichsten überhaupt gewesen sind.
18 Staats.
Und bei Ariane Spass ist da auch gut dabei. Die Russen machen auch was. Wir starten teilweise aus Russland oder Europa startet aus Russland. Das startet auch auf russische Raketen von Kuru. Also da ist jetzt einiges in Bewegung gekommen.
Diese, das haben sie auch anfangs schon angesprochen, so diese Anpassung an die Technik, die im Prinzip immer wieder neue Herausforderungen im Prinzip erst aufwirft. Man kann das ja auch aus dem Computer Informatik-Bereich, das einfach bestimmte Fragestellungen auf einmal, so wie aus dem Nichts auftauchten, künstliche Intelligenz, was hat das für rechtliche Implikationen etc. Im Weltraumbereich ist es ja sicherlich ähnlich, wenn es sich auch teilweise vielleicht etwas anders abbildet. Was würden sie sagen, sind so die großen technologischen Wandel gewesen, wo dann auch so das Rechtswesen, das Weltraumrechtswesen, so ein bisschen Haltung angenommen hat und gesagt hat ups, da wird mal wieder alles so ein bisschen anders.
Naja, zunächst einmal kann man sich die Frage stellen, wofür gilt eigentlich Weltraumrecht? Und das ist eine sehr philosophisch grundlegende Frage, die mit dem Verständnis dessen zu tun hat. Sie finden in der gesamten Weltraumgesetzgebung keine Definition des Weltraums. Was erstaunlich ist für Juristen. Normalerweise zunächst einmal das Refinieren.
Ich wollte gerade fragen, wo der überhaupt anfängt. Also ich meine, wenn der Luftraum über den Staaten immer dem Staat zugeschlagen ist, muss der ja auch irgendwo aufhören.
Auch darüber ist man sich nicht so ganz einig. Es gibt astrophysikalische Möglichkeiten. Wir sagen insgesamt zwischen 80 und 120 Kilometer. Aber was ist nun eigentlich der Weltraum? Wenn man sich der Tatsache bewusst wird, dass das Universum so unendlich groß ist, dass weder sie noch ich es beschreiben können, auch nur irgendwie begreifen können, in Galaxien dort geredet wird, dass Licht ja die metrische Grundnorm ist, also die Entfernung, die das Licht in einem Jahr durchläuft, kann es sich nur sozusagen um den, um den das Erde-Sonnensystem handeln, was wir hier zu unserem Bezugspunkt nehmen können, nämlich menschlicher rechtlicher Regelung. Die Naturwissenschaftler sind sich im Kern eigentlich, dass es eher wahrscheinlich ist, dass es weiteres intelligentes Leben gibt, das wir es bisher nicht entdeckt haben. Aber wir wären doch anmaßend, wenn wir sagen würden, dass wir für diese Wesen bereits rechtliche Regelungen treffen wollten. Und wir müssen glaube ich diesen Fragen, diesen zutiefst auch ethischen Fragen, auf den Grund gehen und es führt uns auf das zurück, was ich so zentral in der Befassung mit Weltraumrecht gelernt habe, bescheiden zu werden. Eine ganz große Bescheidenheit dessen, was wir können, was wir machen. Wir sind so oft so geneigt, dass sich alles um uns dreht, dass wir so endendlich wichtig sind. Wenn Sie alleine sich die Erde angucken in diesem Universum, sehen Sie, dass wir nicht mal eine Stecknadel sind in diesem Haulhaufen. Und das zwingt doch zu einer gewissen Bescheidenheit in verschiedenen Punkten im Anspruch. Dann die Idee, dass wir vielleicht dieses Universum erforschen, weiter erforschen, was für neue Erkenntnisse über uns können wir dabei entdecken. Von dem, was wir bisher entdeckt haben und das Wissen, Wissenszuwachs, acceleriert ja ganz deutlich, beschleunigt sich ja ganz deutlich, würde ich sagen, ist zum einen das Interessant, was wir in der Nutzung bestimmter Orbits, insbesondere das geostationären Orbits, also 36.000 Kilometer über dem Äquator, in der Positionierung von Kommunikationssatelliten weltumspannend gelernt haben, seit 1945 Arthur Clarke diese Entdeckung gemacht hat und die wir jetzt konkret implementieren. Ich würde auch sagen, dass die Tatsache, dass man 1967 bereits so hellsichtig war und die Nutzung durch Privatunternehmen als nicht ausgeschlossen bezeichnet, was nicht so ganz einfach war, weil der Kalte Krieg tobte und die Russen überhaupt nichts mit Privatunternehmen am Hut hatten. Dass man das immerhin gemacht hat, ist auch ein Meilenstein gewesen, der jetzt wichtig wird, etwa für die Amerikaner, die ganz viel über die vollkommen privatisierte Schiene machen. Die Tatsache, dass man damals auch gesagt hat, dass das nicht ohne nationale Weltraumgesetzgebung geht, fordert jetzt viele Staaten heraus. Deutschland hat es bisher nicht fertig gebracht, ein nationales Weltraumgesetz hinzubekommen, was sehr kurzschlüssig ist. Die Tatsache, dass man die Mondressourcen- Nutzung oder die Nutzung anderer Himmelskörper im Kern offen gelassen hat, war, glaube ich, sehr weitsichtig und sehr klug. Bedeutet aber auch, dass wir da in einen neuen Turn kommen, Sie haben nach verschiedenen Wegmarken gefragt, wenn das möglich werden wird, werden wir mit dem Recht auch dort nachziehen können. Das Recht ist ja in aller Regel immer, sozusagen erst nach der Erfindung. Sehr selten ist es so, dass es sozusagen antizipiert eine Erfindung. Das ganze Weltraumrecht ist auch sozusagen nachzüglich. Es kam sehr schnell, überraschend schnell, nachdem 1957 die moderne Weltraumfahrt losgegangen ist. Also das scheint mir wichtige Wegmarken der Entwicklung zu sein, aber ganz offen ist es, wenn es tatsächlich Außerirdische gibt und wie das sozusagen unser gesamtes Verständnis von Recht und von Weltraumrecht mal beeinflussen mag.
Gibt es denn auch schon Weltraumverkehrsrecht? Ich meine, was da so im Maß jetzt alles schon so rumfährt an Robotern, ich meine bisher gehört das alles den Amerikanern. Das macht es wahrscheinlich einfach.
Ich bin ihnen sehr dankbar für diese Frage. Das ist eines der weiteren ganz großen Herausforderungen. Wenn es nämlich so sein sollte, wovon ja einige ausgehen, dass wir in der Zukunft die viel stärkere kommerzielle Nutzung des Weltraums haben, dann müssen wir dafür sorgen, dass wir Verkehrsregeln bekommen für den Transport in den Weltraum, für den Transport durch den Weltraum und für den Transport vom Weltraum. Dies alles wird, Stichwort Space Traffic Management, nur durch Verkehrsregeln gehen, dass wir irgendwann mal klären müssen, ob rechts vor links auch im Weltraum geht, wobei sie wissen...
Und wo ist das überhaupt?
Wo ich und wie die Zuhörer auch wissen, das gibt es eigentlich gar nicht. Aber wir müssen zu solchen Regeln kommen. Man kann gewisse Anleihen an das Luftrecht machen, wo wir das ja haben, wo wir ganz deutlich Dinge haben, aber wir haben eben auch das Problem, wer soll eigentlich diese Regeln überwachen? Sie wissen, im Luftraum passiert das durch den zuständigen Staat, der das für seinen Luftraum macht und da haben wir genau das Problem mit Weltraum, weil da eigentlich eine internationale Behörde dann gegebenenfalls zuständig sein müsste. Wir diskutieren in einem frühen Stadium, ob das etwa die internationale Zivil- Luftfahrt-Organisation sein könnte, weil die damit schon etwas Erfahrung hätte. Aber das scheint mir aus verschiedenen Gründen nicht so sehr angängig zu sein. Es wird immerhin diskutiert, wie ich auch wahrnehme, dass in jüngerer Zeit die eigentlich sonst erstaunlicherweise völlig losgelöst voneinander agierenden Luftrechte und Weltraumrechte jetzt doch ein bisschen mehr miteinander zu tun haben.
Das fand ich auf vielen Ebenen immer wieder interessant herausfahrend. Ich hatte hier vor ein paar Jahren schon mit Markus Landgraf von der ESA gesprochen, der sich ja sehr mit der Idee eines Space-Elevators, eines Weltraum- Fahrstuhls beschäftigt. Das ist ja im Prinzip so der ultimative Weltraum- Bahnhof, wo man sich auch überhaupt nicht mehr vorstellen kann, dass das in irgendeiner Form von einem einzigen Land noch betrieben werden könnte. Allein weil es sich von den Kosten her, aber eben auch von den globalen Implikationen her ja gar nicht durchsetzen ließe, geschweige denn finanzieren ließe. Jetzt ist das natürlich nichts, wo das Recht schon irgendwelche Regeln haben kann, weil davon sind wir ja noch weit entfernt, weil die technische Realisierung noch nicht da ist. Aber wenn sie an so etwas denken, gibt es da schon so Vorstellungen davon oder vielleicht stelle ich mal die Frage anders. All diese, also was man immer wieder im ganzen Weltraum- Business sieht, was bei, was allen Astronauten quasi aus den Poren quält, ist diese unfassbare Globalisierung in dieser Szene. Dieses globale Denken, teilweise auch so ein bisschen Frust mit dem Rest der Welt, weil man sich denkt so Leute, kommt doch mal klar, denkt doch mal so ein bisschen über diesen Planeten hier hinaus. Die Sachen, mit denen ihr euch beschäftigt, das ist so Yesterday. Wir müssen ja irgendwie eigentlich im Wesentlichen an einer globalen Gesellschaft arbeiten. Wir müssen hier irgendwie einen Weg finden, wie wir irgendwie uns einfach als eins definieren und uns nicht täglich in diesem kleinen, kleinen untereinander aufreiben die ganze Zeit. Das wissen wir natürlich alle. So einfach ist das nicht und das wird schon eine Weile dauern. Aber ist so das Weltraumrecht solche Perspektiven, wie vielleicht ein Fahrstuhl und auch die ganzen Erfahrungen, die man jetzt schon in diesem Prozess des Weltraumrechts gemacht hat, im Prinzip so die Blaupause für auch eine globale Rechtsgebung und damit auch vielleicht ein neues Völkerrecht in der Zukunft.
Interessant und sehr gut, dass sie den Kontext ziehen zu dem Völkerrecht. Unser Denken ist ja tatsächlich, den Grundsegmenten hat sehr eng zu tun mit der Entstehung des modernen Völkerrechts. Das moderne Völkerrecht beruht auf der Entstehung der modernen Territorialstaaten, die ihre Beziehungen, anders als noch im Mittelalter, die ihre Beziehungen sozusagen jetzt auf eine neue Grundlage stellen müssen. Es gab Territorialentitäten mit Fürsten, den Souveränen, daher kommt sozusagen der Begriff, zunächst mal personalisiert, später auch versachlicht, die miteinander in Beziehung treten mussten. Wir haben seitdem gelernt, man setzt diesen Prozess so 1648 nach dem Ende des Dreißigjährigen Krieges an, dass wir in territorialen Entitäten denken. Das ist ganz tief in unseren Poren drin. Und was uns im Grunde genommen so ein bisschen deutlich wird an verschiedenen Phänomenen, Umweltverschmutzung vor allem, Klimawandel ist, dass wir mit dieser alten, mit diesem alten Paradigma territorial gebundener Souveränität die Probleme der heutigen Zeit nicht mehr adäquat lösen können. Ich glaube, das ist das faszinierendste, was mich als Völkerrechtler sozusagen umtreibt. Und natürlich kann der Blick in den Weltraum, der ganz andere Dimensionen noch mal freisetzt und die Ridikulität des parzellenhaften Denkens auf dem Planeten Erde besonders vor Augen führt, geradezu stimulus sein, um hier neue Lösungen zu finden. Wobei die Lösungen nicht unbedingt nur sein müssen, dass wir jetzt zu globalen Vorschlägen kommen. Denn es ist wohl richtig, dass, das merken wir immer wieder auch an dem europäischen Dilemma, dass die Menschen schon im Nationalstaat irgendwo, sage ich mal, mit ihren Gefühlen, mit ihrem Sentiment, mit ihren Gebräuchen, ihren Sitten, mit den Geschmacksausprägungen der verschiedenen Cuisines, verortet bleiben müssen. Was wir aber brauchen, ist, glaube ich, eine intelligente Verteilung von Aufgaben. Dass wir uns Aufgaben bezogen neu überlegen müssen, wer macht das am Gescheitesten? Ist es wirklich sinnvoll, dass wir nationales Umweltrecht machen? Ist es wirklich sinnvoll, dass wir Klimawandel national bekämpfen wollen? Ist es dann wirklich sinnvoll, wenn ein großer Staat sagt, ich mache aber nicht mit, weil das schädlich für meine Wirtschaft ist? Und damit das Ganze sozusagen zum Stocken bringen kann. Aber da liegt der Punkt, aber das ist weite Zukunftsmusik, von der ich fürchte, ich werde sie nicht mehr erleben. Aber ich, Sie haben völlig recht, der Weltraum orientierte Blick hilft bei einer solchen Perspektive.
Ich glaube, es gibt sogar noch einen zweiten Weltraum, den man hier noch mal heranziehen könnte, der eigentlich auch so ein kleines Nachhilfebedürfnis hat, das ist das Internet. Und das ist ja im Prinzip auch schon ähnliche Fragen aufgeworfen, wo die nationalen Grenzen nicht mehr so richtig greifen. Urheberrecht, all diese ganzen Dinge, die man versucht hat einzuhägen, nicht mehr so richtig zu greifen. Und da passiert ja, naja ich weiß nicht, ob da viel passiert, aber zumindest ist es ein Gespräch und da hat man natürlich auch das konkrete Problem. Vielleicht sind da so die beiden Dinge, die man dann zusammenbringen muss.
Ja natürlich, wir haben völlig recht. Nicht zu unrecht werden wir demnächst in diesem Institut, was bisher Institut für Luft- und Weltraumrecht heißt, auch noch das Cyberlaw mit Auto ausdrücklich aufnehmen.
Ach guck an.
Digitales Recht. Weil wir der Auffassung sind, dass es eine so, sagen wir so, die digitale Welt ist der Treiber von Globalisierung. Ohne diese vollkommen neue Form von Vernetzung, von Finanztransaktionen, die in Sekunden auch mit spekulativer Tendenz derzeit etwa um die Welt geht, hat natürlich sozusagen der Idee von Globalisierung unglaublichen Auftrieb verschafft. Und insofern sind wir der Auffassung, dass wir nicht nur unter dem Gesichtspunkt Cybersecurity, also Sicherheit vor Cyberangriffen, sondern insgesamt besser verstehen müssen, ob und wie weit etwa Cyberrecht etwas ist, mit dem wir sehr dezidiert auch neu umgehen müssen. Ob das dann ein national radiziertes Recht ist oder ob das per se ein internationales Recht ist. Es ist jemals ein Recht in einem neuen Staatengemeinschaftsraum, der sozusagen eine Community von Nutzern miteinander verbindet. So nehmen wir aber teilweise gar nicht genau wissen, wer diese Nutzer sind, mit welchen Intentionen genutzt wird, wo deshalb eben auch viel anderes passieren kann.
Das heißt, es ist quasi auch wieder so ein bisschen so eine Wiedergeburt dieser Völkerrechtsdebatte, die dann an der Stelle aufkommt, weil man sich eigentlich in zunehmendem Maße über globales Recht unterhalten muss. Nicht nur, was den Weltraum betrifft.
Absolut. Völlig richtig. Sehe ich genau.
Ja, Herr Uwe, ich bedanke mich sehr für das Gespräch.
Ich mich auch für die guten Fragen. Es war eine sehr große Freude, sich mit Ihnen zu unterhalten.
Dankeschön. Ja, und war mir auch wieder eine Freude, eine Sendung für alle Hörerinnen und Hörer zu machen. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören hier bei Raumzeit. Das war's. Geht bald weiter.